on today's visual studio toolbox Aaron's
going to show us how we can write some
code check it into source control deploy
it to Azure without ever having to leave
Visual Studio code hi welcome to visual
studio toolbox I'm your host Robert
Greene and joining me today is Aaron
Powell hey Aaron howdy everyone thanks
for coming on the show thanks for having
me thanks for being so tall my producers
making me sit because you're so much
taller than I am
well at least this way I can reach the
desk so that we can add do these demos
today yeah I can reach the desk too tall
but that's not what we're here to talk
about no um first of all introduce
yourself you are a cloud advocate and
Microsoft that's right I'm part of the
developer advocates team from the
Microsoft my focus is JavaScript Annette
and today we're gonna be looking at a
bit of JavaScript stuff but I've been
doing web stuff for about 15 years now
so I've seen pretty much everything
that's come and go on all so we're gonna
look at we're gonna create an azure
function yeah I'm in node and what we
want to focus on here is visual studio
code and how powerful Visual Studio code
is and how easy it is to bring in github
and bring in Azure so it's all from your
cockpit if you will the visual studio
code you can you can do everything you
need to do yeah exactly
so I've got here the github repo that
I've already created yeah just to give
us a bit of a starting point of a
project and I want to show you how we
can have that full workflow just sort of
start from github but one click to
create a new version this so I'm gonna
start by forking this repo into another
organization of mine okay and then once
that's done we won't need to use the
browser or anything else we can do
everything
just from vs code mmm cool all right so
now that that's forked I'll go and grab
the URL for the git repo and we can
clone that click copy jump over to vs
code then watch the command palette so
control shift P or CMD shift P if you're
on a Mac and we'll use the git clone
pasting the URL of our git repo that we
want to clone and then this will just
ask us what do we want
none of this command line staff or
jumping out to a third-party tool to
work with our git repos I just do it
straight from my editor here so I'm
selecting folder hit clone and it's
going to go away download all the source
code from github itself set up the repo
that I can't open now within this
assumes that you have the get extension
installed in Visual Studio code yes so
this isn't using anything other than
just the github the get stuff that comes
with Vasko okay so we don't even need
like the github extension okay we have
one the conducive more powerful stuff
but we don't need that if we're just
gonna clone some repositories and do all
that sort of thing cool so we'll start
launch that up it does assume that you
have get installed on your machine
though yes yeah and that will I think
that comes with Visual Studio code if
not it's a optional and saw that you can
add okay quickly but now here we go
here's our repo ready to go I have
installed an extension for working with
Azure functions it just gives me some
better tooling support debug support and
things like that it also makes it so
that if I was to hit f5 in my debugger
which I'll do now I can run this
application locally sound debug straight
off visual she okay okay so what is the
application and this application is a
really simple trivia API so I found a
couple of trivia questions online that
you hit an endpoint and as a function
HTTP trigger that will then give you a
list of questions and a bunch of
incorrect answers for those questions
and the correct answer okay use it to
quiz your friends on on something and
then they can try and guess what the the
right answer is and then there's another
end point where we can validate what is
the correct answer
know what are they set and selected was
that correct okay cool cool
right now we're installing the
dependency so we're running an NPM
install to get away node modules that we
need to run this and we're also
installing the azure function core tools
so this is the the host runtime frasier
functions now we need that obviously to
be able to watch it and that's just the
dependency into our project it's defined
in the the git repo that we've
downloaded we haven't had to go out and
install something else so this will just
download all of those on the first run a
you won't need to do that again for
every subsequent run just the first time
Gannett
there we go so now other dependencies
have all installed now you'll see some
logs are starting to come out that's the
edge of function host starting up got
our URL here at the bottom which is our
API endpoint which I can just control
click and follow it'll jump in my
browser and here's the response we're
getting back so this is HTTP trigger I
put a breakpoint in vs code debug what's
happening there and it's then just the
same development workflow you'd have
with any other application using kind of
any other development toolset that you
might be used to but well jump out of
the debugger because I want to show some
other things that we can do with vs code
that you might drop out to other tools
to do normally one thing that you often
be doing if you're working on a project
with other developers is creating
branches so that you can do your changes
and then merge them back in rather than
everything happening in master and
constantly dealing with contracts so to
change a branch in fierce codes really
easy we can just click on down in the
bottom corner here where it says master
which is the name of the branch I'm
currently on or I can use the command
palette I'm just going to use this here
and then I can select to create a new
branch I'm very familiar with how you
get to do all this stuff from inside
Visual Studio yes awesome without having
to I mean you can of course go out to
github or Asscher DevOps and do all the
stuff there yeah but it's way better to
be able to do it from inside Visual
Studio the more you can in Visual Studio
code now so the more you can do inside
without having a context switch because
you know what happens right you go to
the browser to go to as your DevOps your
MSN homepage comes off the next thing
you know it's 20 minutes later and
you've read a bunch of articles you
haven't got anything done not not that
that's ever happened to me I've heard of
this ya know I've always liked laser
focus when I'm going through right so
we'll create a new branch absolute you
can read Brent from which means that if
someone else had pushed a branch and you
want to contribute to that one can use
create bread from but we want to create
a branch ourselves so do that here and
we'll do that update response let's just
change the response that's coming back
from our at that point hit enter and
this is just going to create that branch
and then check it out so swap over us to
that branch and we'll see that in the
bottom corner as well now says update
response I can come over and let's open
up
one of our files good index.js here and
instead of just returning all the
questions because that also gave us an
indication of what was the correct
answer in the incorrect answer maybe we
only want to give people which is just
the correct set of answers okay
sorry just the available answer it's not
just the correct one but all the answers
so we're going to change that and do
questions and we'll return this with we
use a map function so you just to create
a new object so if your a.net developer
this is similar to a select mm-hmm
and we'll create a hair function in here
or that question and here we'll return I
will do the question at selfish chin dot
a question question equals question not
question that's that's not going to be
confusing at all is it and then the
answers will do question dot incorrect
answers so this is an array of incorrect
answer okay and then we will concatenate
okay new array with question dot correct
answer correct answer so that's just
going to combine them all into one array
of home and then maybe we'll do like a
sort on that so that we know we don't
know that the last row is always the
correct one okay so we can save that and
now I can check that in straight from my
editor as well so rather than again go
into another tool or go into a command
line or anything like that I can use
this palette here on the left hand side
click on that and this is listing all
the changes you have got and it's
telling you you have to in a nice yellow
color yep so the first one is that when
I did my install the dependencies the
NPM install I might have had an updated
version so my package lock which is just
telling me here's all the dependencies
that are have in my machine that's just
had an update so I've probably had a new
version since I last run through this
exercise so we can include that one or
we can ignore that I'm just going to
choose to discard the change because if
somebody else has a different set of
packages you don't want to get a
conflict exactly when you put it push it
up to the repository exactly or you
might want it I guess you can decide
yeah so we we can
but he should be using the exact same
packages or it's okay to use different
ones it's kind of a yeah I call and we
can we can actually do that differs well
straight from with inside of yes yes so
I can click on the file and it can show
me what the difference between those two
so we're only really interested in this
index J s file that I've updated so I'm
going to discard the check the other one
and so tell me that those changes gonna
be lost that's fine I'm not interested
in them and now we can add a commit
message before our changes updated the
response is there a way to require that
it will do code yes so it will enforce
any policies that you've got as well so
if you don't put a message in there
it'll say hey can't actually make any
change it will commit those changes to
your repository and then we can hit
there's a shortcut key which is just
ctrl enter or I can hit this check here
which commits that change and it's
because it requires you to stage as well
as commit as you're saying you didn't
staged the change first so do you want
me to stage and commit ok so again
similar sorts of workflows you might
have seen in Visual Studio as well so we
get all that here - yeah that's it
that's all done now our diff doesn't
represent anything's changed because
that [ __ ] changes being committed we can
easily jump back - I can't master branch
and this time I don't have to create new
branch because it's one I already want
master drop back and you see that
changes yep been reverted cool but what
happens you know you brought up before
of conflicts that if I make a change and
I push that and then someone else in my
chain makes a change to the same file
well what wouldn't happen like how do I
deal with that do I have to now go into
github or whatever I'm using is my
source control and tweak on that so
let's simulate two people working on the
same project and enforcing a conflict so
we're just going to do a sort on here
because I want the questions to be
sorted and by default so I'll save that
and again we'll come back here and do
our commit through Visual Studio code
updated response to be sorted commit
like yes and now we want to merge that
branch in so this time I'm going to use
the command palette control shift P and
then we do git merge so what branch do
we want to merge into our count branch
it's like my up there response mm-hmm
and it's gonna go oh we've got a
conflict because you've edited some part
of the same file multiple times and this
is what we will see and there's a bunch
of options that you can see across the
top there as well we can accept the
current change so this is the stuff
that's in the current branch that are on
so on the master branch and that's the
the the top change here which is the the
question is not sought or we can set the
incoming change so what is the branch
that we're trying to merge wanting to
give us which is that bottom half right
we can choose to accept both changes so
if it's like maybe it's actually
additive and we just had like a
whitespace change on the line above we
can merge the two together or I can just
edit the file in line and do that change
oh cool but I really only really care
about the incoming change because that's
a much better way of returning our
response okay so it hit accept incoming
change it's going to apply that on to my
file and then we still have an
outstanding update inside of our source
control tab here on the left hand side
saying that the merge is being completed
but we haven't yet committed that to our
git repo because we want to make sure
that you are certain that you wanted
that merged happen and that the merge
conflict was resolved okay so it is I
can hit commit because it's already
populated in a commit message for me and
that didn't actually work there we go
let's there we go sorry I'd forgotten to
actually stage that cut out that change
so it didn't think that it needed to do
anything because it was like well no you
you didn't do anything yet right I said
nah no except the merge okay
so then that's done and now this is
already inside of my master branch
that's all cool and straight with inside
of our editor very nice very nice I'm
probably the last thing know is that
it's great that it's working on my
machine
yeah but unless I'm shipping my laptop
to production it's not particularly
useful is it I want to be able to deploy
into Azure yes and I want to show you
how you can do that entirely from
code right click publish to Azure
exactly so I've already got the the edge
of functions tools installed and I've
already connected this to my Azure
account so you can see that down in the
bottom it says asher and it's got my
account signed in yep and that is as
your icon down there right there yep
that's where you would go to connect
right yep
and I can see as your functions that
exist across a whole bunch of
subscriptions that I've got so I can
deploy to an existing functions app if I
already had it in there or I was working
in a team environment and someone else
has created the resource and I won't
deploy but I want to create one entirely
from scratch this time so I'm just going
to launch the command palette and we
gonna slate as your functions deploy two
functions that M and select the
subscription I want to deploy to and
then I want to create a new function as
app now I can do an advanced one which
is gonna do a whole bunch more steps of
asking me a lot more questions but if I
just quickly want to throw this up to
test it I'm gonna choose that first
option and give it a name so we'll call
it trivia rap trivia app and we'll hit
enter and selected nodejs run time
because this is a node application folks
doing net no it's like the which version
of Dominic or I wanted to play to for
this Python etc etc I'm gonna use the
node 12 and in the region choose East US
and what this is going to go off and do
and set all those resources aren't for
me
so for an azure functions out we're
gonna need a storage account yeah we're
gonna need a resource crypt first
obviously then we're gonna need a
storage account then we're gonna need
the edge of functions app and we're
gonna want application insights so we
can monitor our application so that's
what it's doing behind the scenes
because it's going spinning all those up
through the azure api's and making sure
that they are ready to go for us and it
will then to play our code base up there
yep sweet all from inside Visual Studio
code exactly yeah we haven't had to
leave our editor except to do the
initial grab of the URL where I get rid
this is really cool like I think a lot
of people know that Visual Studio code
is a great as great as an editor right
so I do most of my development
individual studio but if I just want to
look at the contents of a CSV file or a
sam'l file I pop up Visual Studio code
because it's really really fast and it's
a it's great now you can all
see make changes in there as well but I
think it's perhaps a less known than it
should be which is why of course we're
doing this show exactly Visual Studio
code you would expect it inside Visual
Studio since it's your you know
full-featured IDE that you should be
able to do all this stuff from inside
Visual Studio now we're seeing that it's
also true with Visual Studio code
exactly and it's great also if you're
working across platform team so if
you've got people that are working on
Mac or Linux machines they can have that
same power that we've been used to for
years doing visual studio development so
it's edible all of our agile resources
now and now it's doing it's going to
prepare our application to deploy so
it's going to run some NPM commands to
install the dependencies that it will
require for production we probably don't
want the debug versions we want the
actual production versions and then it's
going to copy all those files up for us
okay we just quickly jump over to the
azure portal and we'll find our resource
group that I have and this is the one
that we just created okay and if we pop
in here we'll see that those are the
resources that we need and we didn't
have to think about we didn't even have
to know what those resources that are
required right it just sets them up for
us
so again if you're if you're wanting to
quickly get it up there and deploy you
can do that straight from the editor all
right I'm just gonna pop up this we know
as well and now that our dependencies
are installed what it's doing is it's
zipping up the edge of functions
application yeah and it's gonna be
copying that up essentially a web deploy
okay you could be doing from from many
different locations
right like most things this takes as
long as it takes it depends on your
network account activity depends on how
big the app is it depends on latency
depends on all kinds of things yep
and as someone who's used to Australian
internet this is happening a lot faster
than I'm normally used to it happening
excellent so that's all set up there
we'll come over to our portal again it's
like through our functions application
and this is load up in a second and
we'll see the funk
that have been deployed under the the
tap here on the left-hand side yeah yeah
we go there's our get all questions and
our check answer mm-hmm and grab the URL
for this in a moment for some reason it
hasn't generated that that's very
annoying let's just click off and click
back on ah there we go
order of execution problem it was trying
to it displayed the URL option just
after I clicked away so pop that into a
new tab here as your functions and tada
yay and the only reason we went to the
browser was to check out HTTPS nice very
very cool all from inside Visual Studio
code exactly fantastic and you said that
with the exception of the Azure function
core tools everything else that we did
because already in Visual Studio code
exactly just the one extension yep just
the one extension to be able to deploy
that was all we needed sweet yeah
awesome all right thanks for showing us
that no that's very cool hope you guys
enjoyed that and we will see you next
time on visual studio toolbox
[Music]
you